My name is Yuta Tokunaga.
I'm the director of the Archi-Depot.
I was excited about creating the entrance door...
...and also thought about how to make the most of the 5.2-meter-high ceiling.
Opening the giant door leads you into a dark space.
You begin to create your own story as you walk around the maze of models.
Archi-Depot is Japan's only museum solely focused on architectural models...
...that used to be overlooked in Japan.
Japanese architects make many models throughout the design process...
...but a lot of them get thrown away.
Many renowned architects' models ended up overseas.
They've tried to keep as many as they could...
...but there is a problem with space availability,...
...temperature and humidity control.
We wanted to preserve them and showcase them here in Japan.
I think there's so much in a model.
The architect's thought processes, joy, anger, sadness and happiness.
Everything is there.
You don't need knowledge about architecture to enjoy it.
The unbuilt models are called phantom architecture.
You can enjoy imagining what it would have been like to see them in real life.
I wanted to maintain the feel of a warehouse.
You're backstage, discovering the models the architects have hidden away.
All sorts of developments are underway in the lead-up to the next Olympics...
...and many old buildings are being torn down.
I think this museum can pass on the architectural references to the next generation.
The models are fascinating .
They're unfinished products,...
...but there are dreams and a future in them.
They're treasures.